excellent job so far I really hope
you're excited about the new tricks that
you've learned for this quiz I want you
to use the dot each method to add the
number of characters held inside these P
tags to the end of them in other words a
number should appear at the end of the P
tag indicating the number of characters
inside it the dot each method lets you
iterate through a jQuery collection and
run a function like so against each Dom
element it's kind of like a
super-awesome for loop that iterates
over your elements I'll give you a hint
if you want to use any of the jQuery
methods on a Dom element within the
function that you pass in you'll need to
use the dollar sign this selector to get
that current element within your loop
without Reese electing using the jQuery
object the keyword this simply refers to
the Dom element itself without all of
jQuery x' additional functionality for
instance dollar sign this text inside of
an each loop will return the text of
each element as each iterates through
the jQuery collection take a look at the
documentation for each and add some
numbers to your page